[MUSIC PLAYING]
DUKE DUKELLIS: All right.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to Google I/O. Thank
you for coming all the way
out here.
I know we're in the
furthest booth here,
but it's a beautiful day.
Really excited to have
you all here at I/O.
And it's just incredible to
see how much apps have really
taken off.
And the functionality you guys
are delivering in your apps.
There's no question
apps have become
an essential part of
everybody's daily lives now,
and that's really great to see.
And something my team
is really, really happy
about is we get to be here with
you helping you succeed here.
And we know this because we're
excited, we see this number--
we're in a million apps
across Android and iOS--
and it's just very exciting for
us to see this kind of usage.
So here's another number
we're really, really proud of.
We've paid out over
$3.5 billion dollars
to app developers in ad revenue.
And we're just going to keep
investing in this platform.
We're going to make
this number grow,
and grow, and continue to grow.
So at Google, we want to
help you develop your apps,
grow your users, and earn.
And today, we're going to focus
here on Earn because that's
where AdMob can really help make
a difference in your business.
And for some of you,
in-app purchasing
is something that works
really well for monetization.
But we know that for most apps,
most users are not paying.
And most apps are
free downloads.
And so that means advertising
is an essential part
for a lot of you.
So it's really our mission
here to really make the best ad
experiences, and to help
developers succeed as much
as possible by
delivering those great ad
experiences to your users.
So these are questions that
we wake up with every day.
We're always
thinking about this.
Sometimes these questions
actually keep us
up very, very late at night.
Things like, is there a better
way to match ads to users?
Is portrait, which we
see more and more--
is that the new horizontal?
Or how do we manage a bunch of
these regional networks that
are coming up and
providing the--
how do I manage all
of them when I'm just
either a small
developing shop, or how
do I use less engineers in
these large, large developers?
And these questions,
they're pretty important.
They really do
keep us up at night
because the thing is,
advertising is really about
more than just making money.
Advertising, we
truly believe, is
what powers the free
and open internet.
So if we get that right, we'll
enable more and more apps
to proliferate and
help you be successful.
Now, we know that a very,
very small, small percentage
of apps, when they're
downloaded, are paid for.
And that means that
most of the apps
that you guys are
building right now?
They're probably free.
Or freemium.
Somewhere in that area.
And as users, I
mean, I love that.
You probably love that.
I bet if you pulled out
your phone right now
and you looked at all of your
apps, I bet almost all of them
are probably free.
And that's great for you,
and you, and you, and me
because we're getting a
lot of value for free.
But here's the challenge.
If you switch to
our developer hats,
that statistic doesn't
look so good, right?
And that's really the challenge.
So the thing that we're
thinking about here
is how can we help
you get more paid
downloads, if that's the part
you're in, and at the same time
how can we work
on that other 95%
of users who don't pay
for your apps in general?
And how can we make money off
of advertising for that group?
How can we do both
at the same time?
So that's something that's
front and center in our minds.
So here's one solution to
this that we've been investing
quite a bit in lately.
This is a rewarded
video ad, and this
is something we launched on
our platform about a year ago.
And we worked with a
number of other partners.
And just in March,
at GDC, we announced
that we're going to
start serving ads as well
from the Google Ad network.
And so this is zeptolab's
Crash Arena Turbostars.
So if you haven't played
this game, it's a lot of fun.
You get to be one of these cars.
You design your car and you go
to battle with someone else,
and you get to have
these constant battles.
Now, in this game you
want to have a great car.
And to make a great
car, you need parts.
And to get parts,
they come in crates.
And to get crates,
you earn these crates.
But when you earn these crates--
you see that timer.
I've got to wait two hours
for my crate to open.
Now, in this case I can either
open it right now by using some
gems-- now, gems cost money,
so that's the IAP side--
or I can accelerate
that and I can
skip 30 minutes of that wait
time by watching a video.
I think I watched probably
24 of these yesterday, or 20.
It helped me move through
the timer very quickly.
So then I can go ahead
and get my parts.
So let's go ahead and
click that skip button.
And this is what happens.
So we see a video here.
We see the timer is
on the upper right.
Usually, it's about
a 30-second video.
There's an end card here
that we saw right at the end.
There's a call to
action on the bottom.
And we're seeing really good
user engagement with these ads.
Now, maybe I click,
maybe I don't click,
but either way I'm pretty
happy because I just
took 30 minutes off the clock.
I feel like I got value out of
this ad, so that's good for me.
And I'm leaving this feeling
happy and more engaged.
We move on from there, I get
my 30 minutes, and we go on.
So here's the thing.
This isn't just about ad revenue
because the developer is making
money off of this,
but every time I
watch a video I'm
getting a little bit more
invested in this game.
And that might
drive me ultimately
to be more likely to
make in-app purchases.
So here we've done
something very interesting.
We've balanced--
not even balanced--
we've gotten the best
of both worlds where
we've gotten some ad revenue
as well as more engaged users.
And zeptolab introduced this.
Once they introduced
our Google demand here,
they saw AdMob revenue
go up by 3x in their app.
That's an awesome stat to see,
and we're seeing more and more.
A lot of these developers who
were strictly in-app purchasing
are now using these kinds
of strategic formats
because it's helping both
the engagement as well
as the in-app purchasing.
Right.
Now, the bulk of
these downloads--
we know they're free.
And like I said, it's a very,
very small number at the top.
There is also a
group down below that
are sort of business
supportive apps
and so forth that
don't charge anything.
But the bulk of
downloads we see today,
they're free or freemium.
And this is really about--
what we're seeing is it's a
high, high focus on developer
experience.
And advertising
maybe historically
was a little less focused on UX.
So we've got to find a
way to bring those two
things together.
And one of the ways we're
doing that is with native ads.
So here we're seeing Perfect
Corporation's YouCam Perfect
app.
This is an app that's had well
over 50 million downloads.
So it's a pretty impressive app.
And you'll see the button here
on the left for the camera.
The next button over, you
can edit your cameras.
Make myself look a little
bit more beautiful.
Can't get enough of that.
Then we also see a collage.
And then if you go and see
the lower left larger button--
what they've done is they've
taken a relevant app ad
and they placed it right
inside their experience.
So it doesn't really
destroy the experience.
And a lot of these
developers are looking
for something that's seamless.
It just fits in well.
It matches the font.
It matches the colors.
Et cetera.
And so you can expect to see
a lot more of these native ads
as we continue to drive into
the better UX experience going
forward.
So we've also been working
on some very interesting
innovations in video.
So one thing we've
done is we took
a huge supply of these
horizontal videos
that advertisers have really
provided us over the years,
because a lot of
these advertisements
originally came from
the desktop site.
And those assets
are all in place.
Now, we've said, gosh, a lot of
apps now are actually portrait.
We'd love to see these
in portrait mode.
But we don't want
the small portrait.
We want the big portrait.
Because we know if we
put big portrait there,
the user engagement is higher.
So we put our machines to work,
and through some really fancy
machine learning we've managed
to take these horizontal videos
that automatically convert
them from horizontal right
over into portrait.
And that means better user
engagement, better CPMS--
so better all the way around.
We've also found a way to
reduce a lot of these videos
from 30 seconds automatically,
again through machine learning,
down to the seven-second shorts.
And that means we can produce
and show a lot of these videos
in smaller places,
and other places.
For example, a third area
where we've been working
has been on cellular networks.
Now, a lot of your users,
when they're using your games
they're on cellular networks.
Now, you might want to
show them some video ads
because the engagement
is pretty high.
But over cellular networks,
that's always been pretty hard.
So we found some
tricky innovations here
where we can deliver these
videos while the user is
on a cellular network.
And that really
improves the number
of users that are
seeing these great ads.
And so as we see smartphones
just continue to proliferate,
and as we see internet
coverage continue
to just grow and grow and
get cheaper and cheaper,
we can expect to see a lot
more videos and a lot more
innovations in
this video format.
Let's not forget about staples.
Banners and interstitials.
So on interstitials,
one thing we've
introduced here in
innovation, and we announced
it last March, is playables.
So these are fun,
interactive ads
that go right into
an interstitial space
so the developer doesn't
have to do anything.
But we see the engagement on
these is really, really high.
And that's really
good for the developer
because it makes you more money.
All right.
So if you were a developer
and you're doing pretty well--
and I have this
conversation a lot.
We've done so well in
these mature markets,
but what do we do now?
We're not seeing
a lot of growth.
How do we go about it?
Well, if I told you if you
took a look at the top 1,000
ad-grossing apps that use
our platform, 95% of them
are live in more
than 200 markets.
So that's a lot.
It's a higher number
than I had expected,
but it sort of speaks to it.
And if you go further than that,
out of all of their revenue
85% of it is not from
their home country.
If you remember, apps in the
early days, when we released--
we released to or home country
or maybe some countries where
it's the same language--
but now it's really
just gone global.
So there's one
simple answer I have
to these conversations, which
is if you want to increase
and maximize your revenue,
a very simple thing
you can do here is go global.
Go global quickly.
And if you go with
the right partner
on this, someone who's
got global reach,
they can help you.
Now, if we think about this
even further into the future--
in the not-too-distant future--
the next billion
users that are coming
online with smartphones-- do you
know where they're coming from?
They're coming from
unsaturated emerging markets.
So the good news in there
is the cost of acquisition
we see in mature markets
versus these emerging markets
is very different.
So a much lower cost
of acquisition if you
partner with the right partner.
And also, in a lot
of these markets
you probably would
expect that advertising
is going to play a
more important part
than in-app purchases.
Not for all of them.
We see some skew
across countries.
But for most of these
markets, advertising
will be increasingly important.
So what does it all mean?
It means that if you
aren't releasing globally,
you're leaving serious
money on the table.
It also means there's a
whole new level of complexity
to your advertising strategy.
I mean, can you imagine having
to go country by country,
finding ad networks that
fit just that country,
and lining that up with
not just one of your apps
but all of your
apps, and managing
that across different formats
where some networks serve
some formats but not others.
So this could get really
complicated really,
really quickly.
So there's got to be
an easy way to handle
all of this complexity.
And this is what we've
been working on at AdMob.
We're trying to solve these
global developer challenges.
And when we say global,
we really mean global.
So for one thing-- because
we're a single platform
and we're live in more than 200
countries, with a single click
we can push out to all of
these countries simultaneously.
So that's great.
We also have some very
big announcements today--
I should say yesterday--
around how to manage this
complexity in a simple way
across both the developer
experience as well as mediation
groups.
All right.
So one of my favorite
things about this job
is I get to go out
and talk to developers
and learn from
developers all the time.
I've probably talked to
hundreds and hundreds
over the last couple of
months, and my team's
talked to several thousand
in the last 12 months.
Like actual conversations.
And this is great.
We get a lot of feedback, and
it's all positive, I promise.
So we're listening
and listening.
What can we do better?
What are your
biggest challenges?
What can we do to help
you earn more money?
That's what we're focused on.
And we really bucket those
things into three main areas.
The first main
area is around just
let's make it dead simple to get
started, to get up and running,
and to manage this
across the globe.
When I'm talking
about that one button.
It works globally.
Help me on that.
The second area is
really around scale.
OK, so I had one app.
And now I need to
get more specialized.
Maybe different areas.
Maybe I've got 100 apps
now, or 50, or even 10
is hard to manage.
So help me on this scale
problem that I've got.
And the third area is, hey,
I've got a lot of data now.
And Google, you've
got a lot of data too.
So can we maybe put these things
together and help me optimize?
Lets make even more
revenue because we've
got the data to do it.
But it's hard and there's a lot
of logistics around that data
and so forth.
So let's work on optimize.
So let's walk through
these three areas.
All right.
So the first area
is really monetize.
And this is always the first
priority the developer has.
Let's get in there, let's get
started, and let's get going.
And it's the first part
you need to lock down.
So the good news here--
when we think about
monetize, what
can we do in the background?
Things that you don't
have to worry about.
Well, we've got a lot
of global advertisers.
And that's good
because that means
if you want to go to
a lot of countries,
you need a network that
reaches a lot of countries.
So you need these
global advertisers.
And I already mentioned
we have a million apps,
but here's why that matters.
It's because over
on the right side,
you see there's at least
1.3 billion unique user
devices that we know about.
We know things about them.
So that means when we're
trying to figure out
which ad to serve to
that particular moment,
we're good at it, and
we're getting better,
and we're constantly
learning from that.
And that means you
can get higher CPMs.
It means the advertisers are
targeting exactly the people
they want to advertise.
So that connection there
is really a win/win
for advertisers and developers.
And we're just going
to keep pressing
that as hard as we can.
And that's a great baseline.
But there's a lot more
we can improve on,
and this is where we really
put on our listening ears.
These are things that we heard.
Can we make simpler onboarding?
Maybe progressive signup?
And can you show me where
the documentation is earlier
or easier in the process?
Things are still
reasonably complicated.
This is tech, and
it's fast-moving.
Format coverage.
I talked a little bit
about native and rewarded.
Can you keep pressing those
around native rewarded video,
especially?
I just want to see
more and more of that.
And can you simplify adding
a creation even more,
and make testing easy?
I want to see exactly
what I've got.
And the thing we
heard the most here
was really about
faster access and, can
you quickly show me
how well I'm doing?
I want to see how
much money I'm making.
I want to see if I'm missing,
if I'm not missing, etc.
Just can you do that really
quickly all in one place?
So these are the main things
that we heard, so we went
right to work on this stuff.
So this is what we've been
doing the last 12 months.
So introducing AdMob Beta.
Yesterday we went live
with this in the afternoon.
We announced it.
This is an entirely new
user experience for you.
We took a hard, hard look
at the developer journey
and we figured out
through there what can
we do to make this
as easy as possible.
And yes, you can go
to AdMob right now
and sign up and go
through this experience
because it is, in fact, live.
All right.
So why don't you
come on up, Ali?
And we're going to
go to a live demo.
So that means I'm
slightly nervous.
All right.
So here we are on AdMob.com,
and we're looking at--
this is Red Hot Labs.
And they're using the
new AdMob experience
for their game Bingo Blast.
Now, Bingo Blast has
about a million downloads,
30,000 five-star ratings, it's
available in the iOS store as
well as Google Play Store, and
it's a simple app that uses IP.
It also uses an interstitial.
OK.
So the first thing you're
going to notice here
is this gray bar across the top.
All right.
Now, this is the all-in-one
immediately how am I doing?
Just give it to me straight.
And we can see from this
that in the last 28 days,
over on the right you see
they made about $1,250.
So that's pretty good.
And let's see.
Now fortunately, let's
say we're looking
at how's our fill rate doing.
This is important.
I want to know.
I've got inventory.
Are you serving ads into them?
So we're seeing about
99.4% fill rate.
That's pretty darn good.
Definitely higher
than most industry.
And you also see this
ECPM is around $19.33.
That's also looking pretty good.
So we've got a pretty
nice looking app here.
It's going on.
Now, this is a pretty
simple account,
and if you were
just getting started
this is the kind of thing
that you'd probably see.
You get going.
So why don't we switch
over to something
that, as you're growing,
would be a slightly more
sophisticated account.
So here we're looking at
the Lab Pixie's account.
All right.
So they're based in Israel, as
you can see from the currency.
And they've got dozens of
apps in the Google Play
Store and the App Store.
So you see this dashboard here.
Now, for them this is
a nice unified view
as well because they're able
to collapse a lot of apps
all into one place.
And you're going to see, as
you have more and more apps,
AdMob becomes more and
more powerful for you.
And you're going to see
these dashboard cards.
See these cards over
here on the right.
As you use more features,
more of these cards
start to appear--
cards that are relevant
to what you're doing.
Now, Lab Pixies-- they use
some of their older apps--
so you can see across
the bottom here.
They use some of
their older apps
to test out some of
these new ad formats
and different experiments.
Some of them-- their
tests-- maybe they're
not doing as well as we saw
in the Bingo Blast slide.
We also, if you just look at the
stats on this performance side,
you see, OK, our match
rate-- yeah, that's
not exactly the same.
I wonder what's going on here.
So that's a little
bit different.
The CPMs are quite a
bit different than we
saw on Bingo Blast.
And then over on the right,
we're using mediation.
And here's one
space where you can
see all of the different
mediation we're
using all in a single place,
how they're each performing--
again, all in one place.
And right now, let's go
back to this bottom left.
So right now we see
our top performers here
are Color Drips and Flood It.
And there's also
this selector here.
So you know what?
Let's take a look at our
top and bottom movers.
So let's see who's moved a lot.
Now, this is one of the
things I heard over and over
in my discussions.
I've got all of these apps.
There's data across all of these
networks, different countries,
et cetera.
Can you just tell
me who's making
a lot more and a lot less so
I could pay really, really
close attention to that?
You should be able to
detect that for me.
So here we go.
So we built this functionality.
So here we see Color Drips.
OK, so they've really
done a good job of--
something's popped there.
Something's good.
And some of these Flood It--
OK, something's not
quite as good there.
But this highlighting--
really, really, I heard,
happy we have this in
the [INAUDIBLE] now.
So we could investigate
what's going
on in Color Drips in a second.
Now, before we do that, let's
go over to the app selector.
So I'm looking over
at this left nav bar.
Now, one thing we
realized is that when
you're working and
managing your apps,
sometimes you're very
focused on one app.
And sometimes you're
focused on all of your apps
at the same time.
You want to do
something and you just
want it to apply all the
way across the board.
And so we split out these
two different workflows
to really get them in here to
match exactly how you work.
So when we're thinking
about the one app side,
if you click on that you can
see all the different apps,
you can search for
the apps you want.
I mean, some of these
lists are thousands long.
You can really
imagine the scale.
So it makes it
quick to select it.
And you also see down
below, if I skip down,
there some account-level things
like reports and mediation.
And we also heard that things
like ad controls and payments--
you know, I need really quick
access to that no matter
where I am.
So we brought that
right to the front.
But then, since we
clicked on an app,
that section expanded
right below Color Drips
and you see all
the relevant things
that you want to do with
the app right there.
And on top of that, we're now
in an app-specific dashboard.
So before we had the
account-level seeing
everything that was happening.
And now we're in an
app-specific dash
that's showing everything that's
happening with a specific app.
So you can see everything
right at a glance.
So here we're seeing our
dashboard across the top
again in gray.
And what's nice
about this is you
see across all of the
networks all in one place.
You see what's happening.
And you also see a
total revenue card.
And you can see that revenue
over the last seven days
versus last week.
We could also expand
that out to 28 days.
See what's going on.
And we see, OK,
how are we doing?
Interesting.
So we had a really
good week last week.
I'm not sure what's happening
in the two weeks before that.
I think we might have
taken our ad unit down.
So we put it back up.
We ran a promotion, etc.
We also see the network
performance down at the bottom,
and we see how we're doing here.
So we've got a match
rate of about 95%.
So not as good as that
last one we saw it 99%,
but still pretty good.
And a CPM of 33,
probably because we're
showing a lot more impressions.
So I'm also looking now
at the bottom right card.
Now, this card basically says--
so there's a network
we're using there,
but we're seeing a
lot of queries go in
but not a lot of impressions.
So that's something we should
probably go investigate,
and we can take you right there.
So what's great
about this is we've
surfaced this insight
right here to your ad ops.
This is not
something engineering
and analytics had to go do.
This is something that's
instantly available to you.
So why don't we click on that
report and go right into that?
OK.
So here we're looking at--
let's see.
Let's go ahead and take a
look at the last seven days
to see what was going on here.
So the last seven days.
This is interesting.
We weren't getting any
impressions through,
so that's not so good.
So let's zoom back out
to 28 days, or 30 days,
and see what was going on.
Last 30 days.
So we had some
impressions going through.
Still a little concerned here.
It's not as high as I
would have expected.
That's not a good fill
rate, so something's off.
Now, what's nice is when we
click that Go See This Report,
it puts some filters in
place for us automatically.
We don't have to type all the
filters in and choose that.
We just went straight right in
to say, this is Color Drips,
this is this network, and let's
take a look at what's going on.
Now, I don't know if this
is a Color Drips problem
or a total network problem.
So why don't we get rid
of the Color Drips filter
to see how the total
network is doing.
So here I am seeing thousands of
impressions are going through,
so the network looks
like it's performing OK.
But we've got a
problem then that must
be not in these other apps,
but in this app specifically.
So that's good intel.
So I can now go
find an engineer,
say, OK, I know
where the problem is.
Something's wrong in this app.
With Something's wrong
in the configuration.
Go solve this problem.
So that's a lot of power that
historically was something
that is hard to go to surface.
OK.
To summarize here, we've got
an app-centric front end,
actionable dashboards,
intuitive navigation,
and richer insights.
And these are a lot
of good features
we just announced yesterday.
We're very, very proud of the
user experience improvements.
All right.
So now let's move on to scale.
Let's say you've
had some success.
You've grown from-- let's
say you took one app that is
immensely successful--
you're trying to specialize--
or you've grown thousands,
and we've seen this before,
thousands of apps--
smaller apps-- all together
and you got to the
same place of success.
So how do you manage all that?
And you need a partner who's
not just an ad network.
You need a platform
that you can grow with.
And that's what we're
really focused on right now.
So in the past, some of
our bigger partners--
I've actually talked
to partners who
have 30, 40 engineers
working just
on things like
extracting data from web
sites from different
networks, transferring it
over country by
country, inputting,
coming back, and cobbling
together all the things.
We looked at that
and we said, gosh,
do you really want to be having
that many engineers spending
that much time on it?
And their answer was,
of course we don't.
We'd rather use those engineers
to make apps, and make our apps
better, and make the apps fit
better, and improve and compete
in the market.
So we basically said, OK,
we know we can fix this.
This is a new problem.
It's a scale problem
because of your success.
So let's get right
to work on that.
So the first thing we did is
we made it enterprise scale.
So we knew we had to
handle thousands of apps,
and so we went right
to work to do that
and we still maintain a
reputation for stability.
That's something we
hear about often.
The second thing we did is
we said, OK, you're at scale,
you're global, and you
want lots of networks.
So we provide support to
over 40 media networks,
and if that's not enough we've
got custom network support.
Third thing we did
was we said, well,
with a lot of those
networks, why don't we
pull in the
information so you can
get all of that
information in one place?
And so we've been
supporting over 20 networks.
And the fourth thing we did
is we enabled campaigns.
Now, what are campaigns?
Well, if you've got one
app and then you grow to 10
and you want to
cross-promote your apps,
these developers were saying,
yeah, I want to use my own ads.
And one thing that's really
nice about this campaign's
capability is you
don't have to build out
your own ad-serving
infrastructure,
or build in specific
ads into a release
and change it in
the next release.
Here you do an ad slot,
and you can manage those
from the server side.
Very simple.
But we knew there was
more that we could do.
And so, again, we
took to the streets,
we asked the questions,
and we said, you know what?
We know we can manage.
We've got problems
that the user said--
we want to be able to
manage media more rapidly,
we want more reporting detail,
we want more of this inbound
aggregation so we don't have to
go site to site, and we want--
some of us launched
on other platforms
before you had rewarded ads.
Can you give us more adopters
so we can tap into demand?
So the good news is
we're solving each
and every one of these things.
And I want to talk
about mediation groups.
We're going to
switch over to demo.
So mediation groups--
I'm really, really
proud to announce this.
This was a tough one.
It's a powerful
new capability so
that you don't have to
manage hundreds or thousands
of mediation chains.
Instead, the concept here is
take one unique combination
of ad network lists,
and countries,
and apply all of your ad
units to that one thing.
So you don't have to create
over and over and over.
And then when you make
changes, it's just to that one.
So as you'll see, these
mediation groups--
it really takes
this issue head-on.
So first, you'll see we went
ahead and clicked on mediation
over to the left.
And that's how we
got to this screen.
And now we're going
to go ahead and we're
going to see this in action.
So let's go ahead and
create a mediation group.
Right.
And as I mentioned,
some of these developers
are using this for
dozens or hundreds
or even thousands of apps.
So to scale with them, I'll
show you how to do this.
So first you choose a
format and a platform.
And the reason those
two you choose first
is the mediation
groups, you tend
to make them specific to
the format and the platform.
Now, let's go ahead
and create a title now.
We're going to call
this one Android
Banners in High CPM Countries.
OK?
And we're going to choose
which countries that we
can include or exclude.
So we're going to choose the US.
And how about the UK, maybe?
Japan.
So high CPM
countries in general.
So we've got our countries.
Let's add some ad units
to this mediation chain.
Now, here's what's great.
It can be across
all of your apps.
They can all attach
to the same ones.
So you do your homework
on which ones you want.
So you attach these apps with
different ad units into here.
So now we've got that group
set up, but now we need to say,
what's the order of
networks we want to serve?
So we already see
AdMob is in there,
and now we're going to
add another network.
So why don't we add--
why don't you just choose one?
Let's add one here from Unity.
Sounds good.
And we can either
choose to optimize,
which is this automated concept
I was talking about where
we pull the data
automatically and then
the ordering is done for
you, which is awesome.
Or we can go ahead and
manually specify this.
Sometimes we manually specify
at the front just in case
the credentials
aren't working right.
And we continue.
And then we answer
our ad unit idea.
So Unity is going to say,
here's an ad unit for this app
and here's one for that app.
And it's very important these
things are kept separate
so we can optimize to each
one because they're going
to give different performance.
We really want to
optimize for every unit,
so we go ahead and say that.
And now we have a
mediation chain.
So that's it.
It's that simple.
We did this across all of
our apps for that chain.
So we see we've got four
different mediation groups.
Great.
And we can dive right
in and see what's there.
We can also see how these
guys are doing across
by just clicking and
dropping that down.
So we just did that group to
people who serve UK, US, Japan.
These other groups, they
serve different formats
in different countries.
And if nobody's caught, we've
got AdMob to catch everything
at the end.
All right.
So we also have
this-- let's see--
we have this consolidated
view of what's going on.
So you see that
bar across the top.
So this gives you queries,
impressions, and fill rates.
That's across everything.
We've done some really
hard, tricky math here
to make sure that when we
say queries, we mean queries.
We don't mean double
counting or triple counting.
That's really
confusing when you've
got a bunch of network
calls all happening
for the same impression. how
to add those up and then not
duplicate or triplicate count.
You've also got the
network [INAUDIBLE]
right at the top, which is a
feature that was asked for.
There's also the possibility
that you've got--
let's say that someone's
come in and said,
hey, I've got a deal
for you. $20 CPMs.
Put me in there.
So we can go ahead
and add that network
pretty easily to
our mediation chain,
or if that network
is already in there.
So let's go right in there.
Let's modify this network.
Let's put $20 CPMs in.
So let's change this
Unity ad to $20.
We change it here, and
instantly that's done.
Now, that's powerful.
Again, across all the
apps and the [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
Another thing.
Let's say we want to add
another app with a new ad unit.
Well, we've already
done the hard work
of the mediation chain.
So we take that ad unit,
and we can attach it
right into the same mediation
group that we already had.
So let's go ahead and add
an ad unit from TriPro.
Let's add that unit, add it,
game ID, again that placement
ID, and we're done.
Just like that.
So we took all of the networks
across the globe, packed it
into that one change,
and we're done.
And it's a really,
really good way
to save hours and hours that
we've seen in the market.
So you've just seen
this in action.
Let's go ahead and
flip back to the deck.
You've just seen this in action.
We're continuing to work on
these features-- simplified
management.
We also allow you to call these
other networks multiple times
now in our new mediation groups.
That's something
that was asked for.
We've got more coverage.
We're now up to 25
networks where we
can pull in data automatically.
We've got rewarded
inbound adopters now
for three networks.
So we've just added Fiber, which
is something that we've heard.
So now let's move
right over to optimize.
So this is something where
we've got data, you've got data,
so let's put it together.
So the first thing we know
is, if you're using mediation,
we have this real-time
CPM capability.
It's a single click and it
lets us bid into every auction.
So if we think we can
make you more money,
we'll go ahead and
give you more money.
So that's been seen to
really improve performance.
Second thing is we have these
optimized refresh banners.
If you have banners,
you probably
notice the speeds on the
refresh are changing.
So why should we ask you to go
do run all these A/B tests when
we have a lot of data on this?
So we're automatically
changing that if you opt in.
We find that even though
we show less banners,
if we pick the right
amount of time,
you get better performance.
The third thing we've seen
is this dynamic allocation
for your campaigns.
So maybe you want to show a
million impressions, or 10%,
but you don't want to lose
out on these really high-value
auctions.
This dynamic allocation lets you
keep those high-value auctions
that make money and
still serve the goals
that you're trying to do.
OK.
So here I want to--
we're basically-- again,
we took to the streets.
These are some
problems that we found.
It's really around
complexity of revenue streams
across these different units.
So I want to introduce you to
this new two-way integration
with AdMob and Firebase
we announced yesterday.
And we're going to dive right
in and see this thing in action.
So the first thing you see
is this app's dashboard.
So this is a revenue card.
Now, here's what's awesome.
You've got AdMob
revenue in blue.
You've got mediation revenue
from other networks in red.
And in yellow you've got
in-app purchase revenue.
All in one place.
This is hard.
And it's really because of
the marriage of Firebase,
which is bringing in the
in-app purchase and our network
optimization products, which
are bringing in the external,
and we put it all in one place.
Also, we have this other card,
which is about user metrics.
So we're pulling this
data in from Firebase,
and you've got some really
interesting new metrics
like ad exposure.
How much are my users
actually seeing right now?
Ads versus the app.
You see 11% in this case,
but with banners sometimes
you see much higher.
And you can see when
it's high or low,
and when things might not
be functioning correctly.
You can also see when you're
running experiments-- are they
helping or are they hurting?
And how's my retention
doing in average sessions?
All right here in
your dashboard.
So we're going to
run a very fast demo.
So this is an account--
it's a complicated account.
You've got the FloodIt app.
You've got a lot of
advertising data.
Not a lot of IAP.
You see 46% ad exposure, which
is pretty common for banners.
And why don't we flip right over
to a different kind of account?
So this is a different one.
This is Bingo Blast, which
you see is really about IAP
and interstitials only.
And a lot of IAP there
that you see in red.
You see ad units
at exposures 0.5%.
That's really low.
So that's an interesting number.
I didn't know.
Maybe we could grow
higher because we also
see, if you scroll down,
that we're at 99% fill rate.
So I bet we could increase
exposure, drop fill rate,
and then we can closely watch
how long these sessions are--
the sessions per user--
and retention, and see
if that's working or not.
So that's a pretty powerful
way to manage your business,
and this automatically comes as
soon as you integrate Firebase.
Very simple.
Link the accounts.
This data
automatically flows in.
You don't have to
set anything up.
So that's a really
powerful innovation
we're very proud to show you.
And then we'll flip back over,
and we'll go ahead and wrap up.
So a lot of things to show
on the AdMob and Firebase
integration.
We've got some great
partners who have seen
some tremendous results so far.
It's really simplifying what
they had a lot of engineers
working on, or just not doing.
So we're giving you that power.
And again, monetize with
this new beta we've released.
Mediation groups.
And Google Analytics
for Firebase.
You put those together-- we're
really proud of this platform.
We're always looking
for new ideas.
So if you have things
you want to tell us,
by all means please
reach out to us.
And this is it.
This is what it's all about.
Make developers like you
as successful as possible
and give you the best ad
experiences that are possible.
Some other things.
Tomorrow morning
at 8:30 to 9:30 is
the session solely on the
Firebase and AdMob integration.
We've got office
hours right now.
And we've got a code lab that's
happening tomorrow morning
from 9:30 to 12:30 where we
have people on-site to walk
through Native and Rewarded.
If you want someone technically
to walk you through everything,
those range between a
half hour and an hour.
We've got a Firebase Analytics
presentation as well.
So thank you very, very much.
I really appreciate
you being here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]